what was it that you saw from jameis
winston coach that
that made you think this is a guy who
can compete
to be a starting quarterback in my
offense
yeah everything from his leadership his
arm strength
um his film in tampa you know his last
season obviously he had a ton of
turnovers
but uh there are so many things that i
think
he does well it's amazing how someone
can be in your division
and you might think you know the player
to some degree and
obviously you don't have the same
intimate knowledge relative to
personality learning
but and then when he's in your building
um maybe how different a guy is and
he was a fantastic leader for our team
very supportive and loyal in that room
uh
i think close with the quarterbacks um
and coming in
in just his first year i i think he
endeared himself to
his teammates he's a tremendous worker
and he's got a ton of talent so
you know he he he made a great
impression on us
sean payton talking about jameis winston
you can find the full interview at pft
and uh i'm sure it'll be on the podcast
and any anywhere else we have our
content a great conversation with sean
payton
he's got a decision to make now look one
thing he said
chris the the idea that they're going to
find out from drew brees
officially soon which we all think is
going to be retirement but
james is going to be a free agent yeah
they got to finesse this they're going
to get him back on the team before he
can be the starter
yeah no no doubt about that you're right
you know and is that situation
out there going to present itself to
jameis winston to where
it's going to be better than the saints
you know i don't know i have a hard time
thinking that right now
jameis winston you get a chance to come
back i don't know if he gets to compete
with taysom hill to be the starting
quarterback we don't know that
i don't know but taysom hill plays a
physical style of football for a
quarterback
there's a good chance he could get
banged up and miss some chunk of
chunk of time and now you get a chance
to be the teddy bridgewater of 2021
and have a good stretch and maybe become
a starter so
i would think he would want to go back
mike remember this though
the salary cap is going down the saints
have their reckoning in 2021 for the
drew brees can
that they've been kicking every year
it's going to be 20 million plus
in dead money just for him there may be
other teams out there
that can pay winston more than the
saints can and that may be a factor
by the time it's all said and done and
there's plenty of other teams are going
to be looking for quarterbacks so
winston could surprisingly be in demand
we'll see
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports